hi guys games comes under way me and
Danny air dryer here we'd spent
economies booth and you just saw pro
evolution soccer idea why don't you tell
me a pro evolution soccer Peter I don't
know anything about soccer I've never
played Pro Evolution before but you have
I guess right I have played I've bought
that and fever every year together yeah
the pro you can't talk about probe
without mentioning thief in the same
breath you kind of candy our way around
as well you could I'm not going to
because the you know with any design of
those games the feature set is often a
oh that's what was in the other game and
oh no that's something new and their
probe Aleutian had a little bit of both
first of all they have updates coming
every week which is been something
that's been in FIFA for a long time yeah
every Thursday player statistics and
injuries stuff like that transfers they
are going to be updated on every
Thursday in keeping with the season so
okay it's become something that's fans
of the other the scottish football game
with the play are used to so it's it's
it's a feature that's been a long time
coming guys they're also getting
something called my club which looks
quite like ultimate team which is the
fifa cards and game when you sort of you
create your squad compete online and
this is similar they said there will be
microtransactions its online and offline
and there are agents so you can you can
is i'm assuming this is part of my
contractions you could pay for agents
which are basically due to will tell you
why this player he'll be better for your
team I think you're basically paying so
you don't have to do any intelligent
work right for that but that's an option
and and yeah and you can play it offline
too so that's that's it interesting and
addition I guess in terms of modes yeah
and they wouldn't talk about licenses
they never can because the licensing
stuff usually isn't wrapped up legally
until a week or two before the games
released but they did a really one
really interesting feature which I liked
a lot which is roller control yeah you
did like that yeah it seems like a
no-brainer kind of a thing rice so
basically I play a lot of coop with my
friends so either to against a computer
three against the computer stuff like
that and whenever you're playing those
games you're sort of like in this battle
for whoever gets to be
next player you hit l1 or whatever and
you know the ball goes through to the
four player never hits at first becomes
the fourth player in roll control you
basically right from the off pick you're
in charge of defense you're in charge of
midfield and your charge strikers and it
sounds really clever because what it
means is then your defense the way you
play defensively means you're playing
with fourth-year people again which is
why you do in single player because the
thing is if you ever do like three
people versus one like human players the
one person like ninety percent of the
time always wins because they're just in
control of the team so it sounds like
I'm reading reading clever addition I'm
actually I'm actually really into that
so there's a lot of ketchup you know
that Konami is doing that you know meet
up with FIFA yeah but does this new
feature Senate like something that might
actually convince people fans I'll see
that the problem is with these games
it's it's like asking somebody to change
like what the favor that they their
favorite thing they get in lunch every
day it's like people are set in their
ways I think they've done a lot for the
on pitch action to make it actually kind
of more Fifi I feel like that the camera
was more like fifa and the passing and
stuff feels like pro AB which I actually
in many ways prefer and it felt good if
that better than last year's it was kind
of their of their first attempt at the
Fox engine stuff this one works a lot
better and it the problem with prior
visit every year it's a really really
good football game and it's just it
really depends whether you prefer before
you look for it and the other
interesting thought I think they had was
they've been answered Mario Gotze the
German international who who scored the
game-winning goal in the world cup is
the cover artists which is actually kind
of like a big up yours too messy cover
artists for other games and which I
thought was a nice touch as well so yeah
that they're gonna have a demo in
September games at second week in
November and same as every other year if
you play fifa always check out the Pro
Evolution demo it's a really good game
and I think this year's especially with
that co-op thing I now feel like that's
the game I'm gonna be playing with local
co-op my friends maybe more than 50 so
you suddenly a both games absolutely
all right Daniel of soccer's room in my
heart for 24 more shooters a year
there's room my heart for two football
games massive heart yeah all right this
is day one of games can we have a whole
lot more content to come stay tuned and
gamespot